bueno el nivel de 10 hay un diálogo
claramente para el nivel de diálogo es
un poco aparece más una pelea con con
francia que bueno y r.unido acusándose
unos el otro para quien es responsable
para iu y
peleando sobre este tema y claramente lo
que deberían encontrar es una manera de
presentarse y encontrar una solución por
un por un tema que yo yo personalmente
voy a cuestionar que sea una emergencia
la emergencia sólo los muertos que son
demasiados estos 29 muertos el otro días
y agua muertes demasiado para los
números de lo de las personas que están
intentando cruzar la mancha no son tan
preocupantes como parecía y estos buenos
o estos 25 mil personas que cruzaron
este año es verdad que son tres veces lo
que hubo el año pasado que es mucho pero
en comparación con el nivel de
inmigración que hay en europa con los
niveles de flujos de refugiados esos
números pequeños al final y el reino
unido de hecho tiene una presencia de d
y un nivel de
solicitantes de asilo que está bien por
debajo de de un país como francia o de
un país como españa en este momento
entonces podría claramente hacer más y
eso es un poco el tema sólo son números
e impresionante no hay estamos muy lejos
de lo que pasó en el 2015 en la crisis
de refugiados en la en europa donde se
hablaba de cien de mil de personas hasta
un millón de personas en 2015 que
llegaron en europa aquí estamos hablando
de 25.000 personas